on va aller travailler en fait là dessus
je vais m'en servir de base pour
imprimer mes cartes de visite à l'aide
de l'imprimante laser
c'est au skylight de la verrière qui
nourrit son projet sa passion menuisier
de profession kevin martin fabrique des
cartes de visite en bois à l'aide du
numérique il peut travailler cette
matière d'une manière innovante
là on a donc une représentation
vectorielle en fait des passages qui on
va être fait du laser et ensuite je vais
déterminé justement bescond coupe où
est-ce qu'on reste un grave avec les
différents codes couleurs les zones
noires seront découpés les parties en
rouge grave est connecté à la découpeuse
laser l'ordinateur lance la réalisation
du projet le résultat est obtenu en
quelques minutes grâce au numérique dans
l'idée que j'en ai ses intérêts un peu
plus justement d'éléments personnel et
personnalisé intégré justement par
exemple ces éléments ces éléments
informatiques dans la nouvelles
menuiseries
c'est quelque chose qui pour le moins
est aux balbutiements marquage laser
impression 3d plusieurs machines existe
déjà
l'idée de kevin martin rassembler ces
outils dans un atelier de menuiserie
itinérant destiné à des particuliers
individuellement ou en groupes à travers
un système de réservation sur la base un
peu d'un camion tout le monde m'en parle
comme ça mais d'un foot run de la
menuiserie entre guillemets donc pouvoir
justement à se rendre auprès du camion
que j'espère créer en fait une sorte d'
applications de géolocalisation et que
les gens souvent puisse venir donc seul
avec soi une idée à réaliser soit un
objet à réparer ou soir justement un cas
doit faire ou à personnaliser un atelier
au qui sera un peu comme on appelle un
été de recherche et développement mais
pour les particuliers c'est le principe
d'un fablab que je veux fait
effectivement diffuser ce qui
actuellement beaucoup de choses qui se
fait justement autour de cette
thématique au niveau de l'écologie au
niveau du recyclage de la réparation en
cours de validation de la création de
son entreprise kevin martin va pouvoir
lancer sa démarche de recherche de
financement pour ensuite lancer sa
menuiserie itinérante